Speaker 1: Our newest correspondent went to see
PAC and interviewed people. And it is some of the
scariest stuff that you will see. This is a series
of interviews done by Malik Snaps. Okay. Malik
snaps. And you can find Malik snaps at YouTube.com
slash at symbol M A like snaps. All one word does
a really, really good job. Now, remember, one
of the questions we've been asking is, okay,
we get that the speaker's go to C PAC and they get
paid and okay, look, I understand that, but who
in their right mind would attend C PAC? Not like
as a media person. Are there teachers? Are there
accountants who say, hey, you know what? I live
in wherever I live in Texas, I'm going to fly to
D.C. and pay for a ticket to see PAC? What sorts
of people are they? And what you are going to
see in these videos is that we are beyond talking
sense into people. These folks, I don't believe,
are reachable. We start with a guy who says the
real enemy is big pharma and tech, and then Malik
gets him to say what this is really about. It's a
globalist cabal, or I should say globalist, right?
But he's not exactly sure who's in charge of it.
Speaker 4: And we need to realize that the enemy
isn't the each other, it's the people, the leaders
of this world and of our government. Who are those
leaders from Big Pharma, The big tech, the World
Economic Forum, the World Health Organization.
Speaker 2: And you're saying, like all
these organizations, like all have the
same people kind of controlling them, not.
Speaker 4: The same people controlling them,
but they all have the globalist agenda in mind.
And I do think there is a globalist cabal of
leaders that there it is kind of cooperate and
conspire together to ultimately create a new
world order and to talk about this stuff out.
Speaker 1: He's hitting all the bullet points,
guys. Globalist cabal, World Economic
Forum, W.H.O., Big Pharma overlords,
the entire thing. One World Order.
Speaker 4: Out. It's an open conspiracy.
Speaker 2: What is their agenda?
Speaker 4: The Great Reset. A one
world government with total control and none where
you don't have your sovereignty or you don't have
rights and you don't have liberty and freedom.
Speaker 1: There you go. I mean, it's that
simple. And one of the amazing things is the
level of confidence that these people have in
their claims. Now, as I've said before, when
it comes to this entire globalist cabal thing.
It is true that those who have a lot
of money. Corporations and rich people
have disproportionately more control than the
average person over their elected officials. Or
we've talked about that. That's not a conspiracy
theory. That's what makes this version even
crazier, which is it's completely unnecessary to
explain what's going on. You don't need to go to
big Pharma. You don't need to go to globalists.
You don't need to go to the World Economic Forum.
Great resettle. We what's happening is actually in
plain sight, which makes it even wilder that they
go to this now. Malik did something interesting,
which is he asked a lot of these folks, Is Biden a
communist or a socialist? And as you can imagine,
it generated some some really interesting answers.
Speaker 2: Would you say Joe Biden is
more socialistic or communist while.
Speaker 4: Socialism turns
into communism eventually?
But I think he wants to really does it.
Speaker 1: And that's another one they repeat now.
Speaker 4: He's socialist,
but sometimes is a communist.
Speaker 2: So can you elaborate
on how he has been a communist?
Speaker 4: Well, a federal vaccine mandate that
fired health care workers that fought against
the pandemic on the front lines. Yes.
Speaker 1: The fact that there was a
period of time during which just
federal workers. Right. I mean,
fundamental if we're talking about communism,
are we talking about total control of industry
wherein Joe Biden would have forced everybody in
every industry to get back? No, that's because
it didn't happen. But this is communism.
Speaker 4: Caring what happened to them
and now depleting our health care system to where
they can't fight against viruses and disease and
mothers and fathers of school and school children.
Speaker 1: You know. Yeah,
Trump did that. Trump disbanded the pandemic
response team and hindered the ability of our
government to fight pandemics and disease. So
so an interesting critique more applicable to
Donald Trump than it is to Joe Biden. Then
we move on to a fan of Mike Pillow. This guy
is a he's angry and he's a fan of Mike
Lindell. And he says, we've got to stop
the mutilation. We've got to elect Trump. But
they're going to try to use the machines to
steal the elections. Where did he get that
idea? We all know where he got that idea.
Speaker 5: It's got to stop now. And
now they're going after our children and
mutilating our children. The hell with that.
Speaker 1: They are going after our children.
Speaker 5: These people got to be stopped. And
it's time for we Christians and we people of faith
and we people of any religion, weak conservatives,
weak Republicans, to all start getting tough on
these people. So, you know, we've got to we've got
to make sure he gets elected. Now, they're going
to try to steal the election from us again. Right.
Speaker 2: You think they will try to do that?
Speaker 1: Remember, Trump
tried to steal the election.
Speaker 5: Well, they'll do that
mostly with the electronic machines.
I was listening to Mike Lindell earlier.
Speaker 1: Did you see him pause. It almost
seemed like he was going to call them Mike Pillow.
Speaker 5: And he said, We need to take all the
electronic voting machines in the country,
melt them down and turn them into prison
bars. And he's right. That's a great analogy,
a great metaphor. These people are stealing our
elections. And every country, they just stole
the election in Brazil from Bolsonaro and put
a criminal in there, a felon.
Speaker 1: That didn't happen.
Speaker 5: It was in a prison until recently.
They're going to go after Orban in Hungary.
He's another good man and a good leader. And
Bukele in El Salvador has just perp walked
40,000 members of MS13 and other gangs into a
prison in their boxer shorts. He's not messing
around. That'll help their economy tremendously.
Speaker 1: This guy is out of his mind,
and Malik follows his instincts
here and he says, Can you explain
to me what Joe Biden's biggest failures are?
Speaker 2: What are some of the things that you
think the Biden administration has failed to do?
Speaker 5: Oh, God. Open borders, Afghanistan.
Speaker 1: Remember, open borders policy
at the border has not dramatically
changed from Trump into Biden.
Speaker 5: San was a disgrace
and a humiliation for this country.
Speaker 1: The Afghanistan withdrawal
was exactly what Trump would have done. Only now
does Trump come up with what he would have done
differently. For about six months, Trump was asked
many times, What would you have done differently?
He couldn't. He couldn't express anything.
Speaker 5: And he gave. And the Chinese he's
obviously in bed with the Chinese. He's
he's on his knees in front of in front of
President Xi of China. And he's not praying.
Speaker 1: There it is. That's some imagery on
his knees in front of Xi. But he is not praying.
He is doing something else. Same guy, by the way,
before we move on, brings up the term sub
humanoid, which was an interesting moment.
Speaker 5: In speaking to President
Trump over the last couple of months,
I've realized this guy is laser focused
and locked on. He's ready to go for 2024.
Speaker 1: By the way, who is this
guy who's been speaking to Trump?
That's I don't even know who this guy is.
Speaker 5: He has to win this. It's about the
future of humanity. If we let these sub humanoids
continue to control and destroy our country,
we're in real trouble. And, you know,
then our only hope will be God Almighty,
He'll have to come down and smite these
people like he did in Sodom and Gomorrah.
Speaker 1: Right now, by the way, as funny
as that, he's talking about subhuman, not sub
humanoid. It's not really funny. We laugh to avoid
crying, but this is part of what the right does.
They dehumanize. They dehumanize and they act as
if and spread the idea that some of our fellow
Homo sapiens are not really human because of their
political beliefs. Then we go to a guy who was
wearing a brick suit. You'll see what I mean in
a moment. He was he was wearing the brick suit,
I guess, to support the wall, which isn't actually
made of bricks. He was asked what Biden did wrong.
And the guy's very confused about the wall.
Speaker 6: This is my brick wall suit. And that's
why they call me brick suit. And it's signifies my
support for strong border barriers, specifically a
border fence between the United States and Mexico.
Speaker 2: What is something that Joe
Biden has that you don't really like?
Speaker 6: President Trump had built much
of the wall that was requested and much more was
ready to be built. The materials were right there
at the border. The contracts were already signed.
The workers were already working on it. And when
Biden came in on first things he did in the first
few days as he stopped all construction. But that
doesn't mean America stopped paying for it. We'd
already bought all the materials. We were already
paying all the contractors, and we continued
to pay them millions of dollars a day to do
nothing and no more Wall fencing was constructed.
Speaker 1: Now, most of that really isn't true.
The reality is that Donald Trump had planned to
spend about 16 billion on the wall. 10 billion
was going to come from funds diverted from the
Defense Department with questionable legality.
And then just under 6 billion was going to come
from a congressional appropriation and then 600
million was going to be forfeitures collected by
the Treasury Department. That's based on a 2021
Congressional Research Service report. When Biden
did stop the construction of those pieces of wall,
there were some steel panels and piping left at
the construction sites. They're almost all being
used elsewhere. The stuff didn't get thrown
out. Some of it was donated to Texas for a
state border wall, which is kind of the same
thing that Trump was trying to do with it. So
I don't even know why they're so upset. Some of
it was used to close breaches in a Texas levee,
which seems like a pretty damn good idea. And
then, of course, much of this, like the guy says,
millions of dollars a day. I found no confirmation
of that whatsoever. Same guy was asked, is Biden a
communist or a socialist? And the guy says, he's
neither. He's a puppet. Well, who's the puppet
master? The guy doesn't know it.
Speaker 2: Would you say Joe
Biden is a socialist or a communist?
Speaker 6: I would say he's a puppet. I don't
think he has any particular political ideology.
I think he just does what people tell him.
Speaker 2: To do, which is to puppet up.
Speaker 6: Hard to say that,
to say there's suspicions there.
Speaker 2: But what what are those,
like tough suspicions people.
Speaker 6: In the previous Democratic
administration.
Speaker 2: Are.
Speaker 1: So there is the idea. Obama now he
thinks it's Obama who is controlling Biden.
Very, very interesting idea. Then
we go to a young guy who was asked,
is Biden a socialist or a communist?
Speaker 2: Would you say Joe Biden is
more of a socialist or a communist?
More of a socialist? Here are some
of those socialistic policies. I think in
particular the environmental stuff. Yes.
Speaker 1: He's a socialist
because of the environment.
Speaker 2: On the Keystone XL pipeline,
killing all those jobs. But you know,
he wants to get rid of gasoline cars and, you
know, by 2030 or 2035. Why? Because he thinks
that CO2 emissions, CO2 emissions are bad for
the environment. He just wants to keep everybody
dependent on the government all the time.
Speaker 1: And of course, you do that by
switching to electric vehicles.
Speaker 2: That's a problem. Yep.
Speaker 1: So these are the people that go
to CPAC. Another another young guy here,
also socialist or communist.
Speaker 2: You think Joe Biden
is more like a socialistic or communist?
Probably both. Yes. That's the that's US's.
Tell me more about those policies. So,
like Marxism is a big part of communism.
Speaker 7: And Marxism pits one group
against another group. And his policies
do that. So there you go. You know, there's
like an oppressed group and how to oppress
group and impediment put people together.
Speaker 1: Isn't it obvious to you guys?
Obviously, Joe Biden is a socialist. Marxist
inspired communist. Same guy and others asked
when two men get married, what do you make of
that? Quite a range of answers, I will admit.
Speaker 2: Can you finish the
sentence? Two men getting married
is unnatural. Two men getting married is.
Speaker 4: You can do whatever you want. I'm
a Christian. I don't necessarily agree with it.
Speaker 2: Two men getting married is legal in
America. Two men getting married is not a big
deal. It's too bad. Getting married is not for
that at all. I not. I'm not that liberal. Why?
Because you can't procreate to make enough to
procreate. I'd rather have two sane gay men
adopting as opposed to cranky parents. Two
men? Getting married is not marriage.
Speaker 7: Traditionally, marriage is
between a man and a woman.
Speaker 1: Tradition.
Speaker 7: It's something else. It's not marriage.
Speaker 2: Do you think two gay men should have
the same rights as a heterosexual couple? What do
you mean by rights? Like just human rights or what
are human rights? Too bad getting married is.
Speaker 5: It's a sin. I mean, you know, look,
I have nothing against homosexuals, but.
Speaker 1: You couldn't tell guys.
But he has nothing against gay people.
Speaker 5: You know, as long as I have a live and
let live policy and philosophy, I don't care who
you want to sleep with, just say out of my face
about it. Once you get up in my grill and you're
you're a homosexual and you want to start telling
me how my kids are going to be educated in school.
Speaker 1: And of course, gay people famously go
and get up in people's grills and
say, this is what you should do.
Speaker 5: That's where I draw the
line. Then the gloves come off and
we're not going to have a good time there.
Speaker 1: It is a very, very powerful
declaration. So we've answered our question, Who
goes to CPAC? It's these people. I believe they
are lost causes. Now, if you have a family
member who's like this and for sort of like
pseudo entertainment purposes, you want to see
if you can talk sense into them by all means.
But the idea that we are going to win elections
by disabuse these folks of all of these ideas,
I don't think it's going to happen. I think we
win by voter turnout and by mobilizing those who
are already thinking a little more clearly than
these folks. Let me know your thoughts. Make sure
to subscribe to the YouTube channel, please.
We are fighting our way, fighting, fighting
towards 2 million subscribers. And you can get
us one closer by hitting the subscribe button.